après le symbole de l'éducation visé il
y à peine deux semaines dans ce meurtre
de samuel pâtissent est aujourd'hui
l'église qui est la cible des actes
terroristes
oui au delà des symboles
je vais pas revenir sur tout ce qui a
été dit on assiste surtout à la
déliquescence à la dégénérescence à la
disparition au délitement de l'état
il n'y a plus d'état en france il n'ya
plus d'état qui fonctionne correctement
alors on est toujours dans l'émotion
déplorent chacun fait des discours
outrés des discours larmoyant plus
jamais ça on va agir et les responsables
divers et variés et ça vaut pour
différentes majorités qui se sont
succédé vienne déploré un nouvel acte
odieux le tragique alors que quand on
réfléchit un petit peu qu'on regarde de
façon tout à fait des passionnés les
choses
que s'est il passé en réalité qu'on
regarde et on peut pas dire que la
france n'est pas un pays où il n'ya pas
des policiers et si on regarde le nombre
de policiers par habitant on est sans
doute l'un des pays qui est le mieux
doté en la matière mais que font les
policiers
on le voit avec ce premier confinement
et ce deuxième confinement ils vont
surveiller les français c'est bien sûr
le problème c'est le couvre-feu le
problème ce sont les manifestations il
faut sans arrêt réprimer comme disait
quelqu'un
la maison brûle et on regarde ailleurs
donc bien sûr il ya le problème de la
hiérarchie des normes c'est évident il
faudra sans doute adapter notre notre
état de droit pour répondre à ces jeux
les gares nouvelles menaces
elles ne sont pas nouvelles parce que
dès que vous parlez quand vous échanger
avec les services de renseignement ce
que je fais régulièrement les menaces
sont parfaitement identifiés est
parfaitement connu et
rien n'est fait et ensuite on déplore
encore en attente on a parlé tout à
l'heure j'ai vu où différents
intervenants de ce qui est arrivé à
samuel tati mais là encore beaucoup
d'enseignants qui étaient ses premiers
le core v comme on les appelait dans une
espèce de catharsis général et encore
une fois larmoyante avait alerté leur
hiérarchie
on les laisse tout seul tout seul
complètement abandonné et quand ils font
quand ils font remonter les informations
on mais si j'ose dire la poussière sur
le tapis quand vous regardez la question
de l'éducation nationale quand vous
regardez la question de la justice il
faudrait cinq fois plus d'un magistrat
la justice ne fonctionne plus
en france où elle fonctionne demande et
d'une façon tout à fait j'allais dire
surprenante pour judiciariser pour
emprisonner de façon parfois préventive
les gilets jaunes donc les priorités ne
sont pas là où elle devrait texte n'est
pas qu'un problème de moyens avec un
problème d'effectif c'est que l'on fait
le faire des tâches on assigne des
tâches qui ne sont pas celles qui sont
attendues par les français aujourd'hui
les français ne sont plus protégés les
français ne sont pas entendus et en plus
on va encore le lait les réprimander les
centres fermés alors que là encore une
fois on voit qu'il ya une crise moi je
parle plus de crise parce qu'une crise
ces épisodes qui comme son nom l'indiqué
est un problème de fond structurel quand
on voit la situation de l'hôpital
la disparition des vies donc à vous
entendre vous mettez sur le même plan la
lutte antiterroriste à mener par les
autorités françaises et la lutte contre
les manifestations des gilet jaune c'est
quand même pas tout à fait la même
thématique est ce que tout ne peut pas
être mené de front à la fois l'allemande
l'antiterrorisme c'est bien ce que je
suis en train de décider de nous
expliquer tout ne peut pas être mené de
front il y à des combats qui sont
prioritaires
est-ce que la priorité aujourd'hui c'est
d'aller excusez moi l'expression en
garde et les français pour surveiller
s'ils sont bien dans leur soupe à 19
heures ou est ce qu'il ya des des
menaces et notamment la menace islamiste
qui est de plus en plus prégnante et un
moment faut arrêter de faire l'autruche
donc c'est bien un problème de
fonctionnement de métal des des
priorités qui sont assignées aux
différents services publics
et c'est bien ça qu'il faut il faut
revoir parce que les forces de l'ordre
ne peuvent pas être elles sont pas
infinies et quand vous avez humilié de
policiers sont mobilisés notamment pour
les couvre feux et toutes ces cinq jurys
effectivement on n'est pas tout à fait
efficace mais ça s'apprend aliciens qui
sont réquisitionnés à la fois pour faire
respecter le confinement le couvre-feu
et est là et pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
non mais est ce que c'est le rôle d'un
policier d'aller faire le garde chiourme
le garde champêtre où le garde malade
un policier est là pour protéger la
population et assurer effectivement
l'ordre que tout se fasse bien
évidemment ce que je vous dis à pia sans
doute à revoir toute l'organisation de
notre état qui en fonction des nouvelles
menaces et arrêter d'avoir des policiers
qui font des tâches subalternes
aujourd'hui nous avais moi je parle
beaucoup avec des policiers ternois
vous savez que que 70% du temps de
travail est un policier dans n'importe
quel commissariat qui fait de
l'administratif
quand vous allez à l'hôpital 70 pensant
des chefs de service et des médecins
fort de l'administratif
est ce que c'est bien leur rôle c'est ça
la question dans quel choc
veut pas bouger et encore 10 à cela mais
ça n'a pas du tout bougé
il ya beaucoup de discours ça n'a pas du
tout évolué
malheureusement il suffit de parler avec
les gens de terrain pour qu'il vous le
que ce soit d'ailleurs à tout à tout
niveau à toute échelle
on est dans une société qui est devenue
folle qui meurt d'une administration
pléthorique et on fait des beaux
discours
voilà et ça c'est un vrai problème parce
qu on le constate tous les jours
la justice ne fonctionne pas le maintien
de l'ordre ne fonctionne pas ou ne
fonctionne que pour les gentils gens
pacifiques convient terrorisé dutil est
éborgné là ça fonctionne la justice
sanctionne et de façon expéditive
quand il s'agit de mettre les gens en
privant parce qu'ils sont des menaces à
l'ordre public etc
il ya combien 4000 en entendait tout à
l'heure puis j'ai s ils sont
parfaitement identifiés et et
malheureusement ça continue parce
qu'encore une fois il ya un problème de
priorisation les activités des
différents fonctionnaires
donc on fait des choses subalternes ont
fait beaucoup d'administratif alors que
tous les moyens il devrait être tendue
vers les principales menaces un peu
temps paraît évident ça me paraît
élémentaire mais pour autant ce n'est
pas que ces derniers éléments
quand j'entends ces accusations
d'islamologie sme alors c'est vrai qu'il
ya parfois quelques personnes qui sont
un peu tendancieuse et qui laisse aller
comme ça qui ne voient pas forcément la
menace au nord je sais pas d'un
humanisme
peu importe mais je voudrais quand même
rappeler que tous les premiers ministres
elles mêmes les présidents de la
république qui se sont succédé ont
fricoté avec beaucoup de pays qui ont
financé encourager le terrorisme la
ligue
l'arabie saoudite le qatar a certains
qui ont aussi financé des campagnes
électorales or moi je veux bien que le
problème ce soit les universités et
certains livres qui sont diffusés et qui
vont enflammer les esprits
il faut pas nier le problème de
l'armement des esprits mais je pense il
ya aussi beaucoup d'hypocrisie de toutes
ces politiciens qui viennent aujourd'hui
nous l'expliquait l'état le droit etc
mais qui sont allés pour vendre des
armes pour vendre un certain nombre
d'industries sap a toujours marché
d'ailleurs et qui font à miami avec des
pays qui ne sont en rien des démocraties
est qui et qui est financée ensuite le
sport enfin un certain nombre de choses
et qui ont un discours tout à fait
ambivalent donc il faut savoir ce qu'on
veut et sans doute retrouvé notre
souveraineté
dixième à une chose que vous n'avez pas
le sentiment que dans la foulée du
d'humeur de samuel bâti le 16 octobre il
ya à peine deux semaines est ce que vous
n'avez pas le sentiment qu'un
électrochoc en tout cas ça a été
commentée de la sorte à cette réaction
de l'exécutif d'emmanuel macron de jean
castex de l'ensemble des ministres de la
justice de l'intérieur sur le front sur
le pied de guerre pour tenter d'apporter
une réponse alors aux moeurs de samuel
paty et plus largement à la menace
terroriste est ce que vous n'avez pas le
sentiment qu'il s'est passé quelque
chose comme le disent de serre quand la
guerre
ça c'est fait là ça sert à rien de dire
on est en guerre
ça sert à rien de plastronner de faire
des rodomontades et de bomber le torse
et d'avoir le montant ou comme ça veut
dire ça ne passera pas ça ne passera pas
là nous sommes dans l'émotion et à
chaque nouvel attentat nous avons cessé
ses pleurs cette prise de conscience
avouez c'est électrochoc mais vous voyez
que ça que c'est complètement inefficace
ça ne produit aucun effet que ça ne sert
à rien et que ça continue
malheureusement des attentats continuent
d'être perpétrés donc ch'ti en est en
guerre la guerre il faut la faire pas
tous les musulmans
bien sûr je tiens à le préciser
ce qui se réclame d'un islam politique
qu'il faut combattre qu'il faut
éradiquer
et ça c'est pas du discours ce sont des
isles